sea-level rise will be one of the
greatest challenges we face in the next
century how high seas rise and how soon
has a lot to do with what happens here
Antarctica holds the largest chunk of
ice on earth its western portion alone
contains enough ice to raise sea levels
by more than 3 metres and it's in big
trouble largely because of this the
Thwaites glacier its face towers as high
as a six story building and extends for
120 kilometers across the coast of West
Antarctica making it about the size of
Florida it's a humongous glacier that
reaches right into the heart of West
Antarctica and that's a major problem
because in the past couple decades it's
become increasingly clear the threats
glacier is falling apart
[Music]
these are portraits of a vast rugged
treacherous continent which has
challenged man since first he could sail
beyond the limits of his horizon and
Arctica this is the Antarctic Ice Sheet
it's thickest in the Middle where years
and years of snowfall compacts into ice
as the middle builds it pushes ice out
towards the oceans for your glaciers and
the part of a glacier that floats on
water is its ice shelf today manmade
climate change is warming the air and
water around Antarctica causing each
side of the ice sheet to melt but at
very different speeds the eastern ice
sheet lies mostly on high ground above
sea level which keeps it relatively safe
from warm ocean water that means it's
melting slowly and remains relatively
stable but Western arctica is different
most of it lies below sea level that
means as it thins water can undermine it
possibly kick-starting a more rapid
collapse it's why West Antarctica is
considered the most important piece of
ice in the world when it comes to
climate change here's another view of
the bedrock underneath Antarctica's ice
sheet the green yellow and red parts are
land above sea level
like in East Antarctica but these blue
areas in western Arctic are are all
below sea level this area where the
bedrock slopes continuously for more
than a mile down and deep into the
center of Antarctica is the fight's
glacier and it could be the most
dangerous clasher in the world
surrounded by three mighty oceans but
these are as much a part of Antarctica
as her highest mom right now waits is
barely hanging on in the past 30 years
the front of Thwaites ice shelf has lost
a lot of ice causing it to retreat
backwards with a smaller ice shelf to
slow the flow of ice the flow of the
glacier speeds up but the bigger problem
is the closures grounding line the final
point where the glacier rests on the
bedrock that grounding line has been
shifting backwards as warm ocean water
reaches underneath the ice shelf it's
moved 14 kilometers since 1992
so I said used to be on land becomes ice
that is floating on water raising sea
levels the downhill slope of the bedrock
means that as the grounding line moves
back it lifts an even bigger slice of
ice behind it off the land and into the
water and that accelerates the flow of
the glacier into the sea the amount of
ice flowing from Thwaites has doubled
over the past thirty years and already
contributes four percent to global sea
level rise and scientists have recently
detected a huge cavity two-thirds the
size of Manhattan down here scientists
believe this could mean Waits's collapse
is inevitable how soon that happens is
hotly debated leaving continent is
awakening slowly at first but with ever
gathering momentum the complete collapse
of 3/8 will take centuries and it's
affected by many different things from
the temperature of the ocean currents to
the makeup of the bedrock but research
shows that humans can possibly slow or
even stall its collapse by curbing
greenhouse gas emissions soon that's
important because some scientists
believe collapse could start this
century while others say it's already
underway the collapse of weights would
add about half a meter of sea level rise
and trigger a much bigger catastrophe
because the weights reaches into the
middle of West Antarctica its collapse
could cause the rest of the ice sheet to
collapse with it resulting in more than
3 meters of sea level rise in the next
few centuries that would submerge not
only Miami and southern Bangladesh but
also parts of the Netherlands and New
York City so while there's a lot of
uncertainty around Thwaites one thing is
clear once it starts to collapse it
won't stop
[Music]